Gestern hat das Weltraumunternehmen "SpaceX" etwas geschafft,
das sogar die NASA höchstpersönlich für unmöglich gehalten hat!
Eine "Falcon 9" Rakete startete, setzte elf Satteliten in der Erdumlaufbahn aus
und landete schließlich wieder sicher auf der Erde.
Warum das so spektakuläre Neuigkeiten sind,
erfahrt ihr jetzt in diesem Video!
Es war ein besonders wichtiger Tag für "SpaceX" und Firmengründer Elon Musk.
Nicht nur versucht das Unternehmen seit fast einem Jahr, eine Rakete wieder sicher landen zu lassen,
und ist dabei bereits drei Mal gescheitert, der letzte Raketenstart im Juni diesen Jahres
verlief auch noch katastrophal, nachdem "SpaceX" über 20 Starts hintereinander ohne Probleme
über die Bühne gebracht hat!
Die Erfolgsserie war also gebrochen!
Und obwohl die Landungen auf hoher See immer nur Experimente und nie die Hauptmission waren,
stieg der Druck auf das Unternehmen.
Also startete um halb 9 Abends Ortszeit im Cape Canaveral in Florida die "Falcon 9" Rakete.
Sie flog mehrere Minuten lang über
200 Kilometer Richtung Weltall.
bis sich die erste Stufe von der zweiten trennte.
Die zweite machte sich weiter auf den Weg Richtung Erdumlaufbahn,
wo dann für einen Auftraggeber elf
Satelliten ausgesetzt wurden
und die Hauptmission erfolgreich abgeschlossen wurde.
Diese Auftragsarbeiten macht "SpaceX" schon lange
und damit verdient sich das Unternehmen die Brötchen.
Aber nun zum experimentellen und vor allem spannenden Teil.
Nämlich der Nebenmission
Die erste Stufe einer Rakete in der sich
zum Beispiel der Booster und der große
Tank befinden ist der wertvollere Teil
einer Rakete.
Dieser drehte sich nach der Trennung und
begann wieder Richtung Erde zu fallen.
Mit kontrollierten Boosts landet die
Rakete sicher auf dem Erdboden.
etwa zehn Kilometer vom Startpunkt entfernt
mitten auf einem riesigen "X".
In der Animation ist die Rakete übrigens
ein Bleistift weil die Proportion dieser
Landung so sind wie ein Bleistift den man über das Empire State Building wirft
und der dann aufrecht in einem Schuhkarton landen soll!
Es ist ein unglaublicher Balancierakt
eine Rakete wieder sicher auf der Erde
landen zu lassen.
Elon Musk selber vergleicht es mit
einem Bleistift den man während eines
Wirbelsturms auf der Fingerspitze balancieren soll.
(Und ich kann das nicht einmal ohne Wirbelsturm.)
Sogar die NASA ist vor einigen Jahren und nach einigen Überlegungen und Prüfungen
zu dem Schluss gekommen, dass
ist viel zu schwierig wäre eine Rakete
sicher auf der Erde landen zu lassen.
Jetzt höre ich schon einige sagen:
"Aber genau das hat doch vor kurzem 'Blue Origin' gemacht!"
Und das stimmt auch. Teilweise. Blue
Origin ist ein amerikanisches
Unternehmen mit dem Ziel Weltraum
Tourismus zu betreiben.
Am 23. November
hat die Firma eine unbemannte Rakete etwa 100 Kilometer in die Luft befördert
und die Rakete wieder sicher auf dem
Boden landen lassen.
Mit hundert Kilometern Höhe haben die
Wissenschaftler übrigens exakt die
offizielle Grenze zum Weltraum
überschritten.
Das ist definitiv eine schwierige
Aufgabe
und man sollte auch "Blue Origin" gratulieren!
Aber es liegen Welten zwischen den
beiden Versuchen.
Eine Rakete in den Weltraum zu befördern
und etwas in die Umlaufbahn zu bringen,
sind komplett unterschiedliche Dinge!
Zum einen ist die "SpaceX" Rakete
viel größer und schwerer
und war mehr als doppelt so weit von der Erde entfernt.
Aber was noch viel wichtiger ist:
Sie hatte eine Geschwindigkeit zur Seite.
Ein kritischer Faktor um in die
Erdumlaufbahn zu kommen.
Was viele Menschen nicht wissen ist,
dass das schwierigste an einem Raketenstart
nicht die Höhe ist, sondern die
Geschwindigkeit parallel zum Erdboden.
Die "ISS" kann nur um die Erde kreisen,
weil sie so eine hohe Geschwindigkeit
zur Seite hat und quasi zu jedem
Zeitpunkt an der Erde vorbei fällt.
Ohne diese Geschwindigkeit
würde sie, langsam aber sicher, auf die Erde
zurückfallen!
Die Schwierigkeit der beiden Versuche wurde
mit dem Einparken eines Gefährts verglichen.
"Während 'Elon Musk' einen SUV rückwärts eingeparkt
hat, hat 'Blue Origin' ein Fahrrad angekettet."
(Das haben "Experten" gesagt, übrigens.)
Gradlinig nach oben zu fliegen und wieder
zu landen, ist etwas das "SpaceX" schon
seit langem mit ihrem "Grasshopper Tests"
gemacht haben.
Aber warum die ganze Aufregung dann ist
die Rakete halt eben wieder auf der Erde gelandet"
Und jetzt?
Na ja, jetzt sofort noch nichts, aber
auf Dauer ist das die Zukunft der Raumfahrt!
Stellt euch vor:
Ihr fliegt in den Urlaub und nach jeder Landung
wird das Flugzeug komplett zerstört
und ein neues muss gebaut werden.
Jedes Ticket würde dann
über 1,5 Millionen Euro kosten!
Und,
genau das passiert gerade in der
Weltraumfahrt. Bei "SpaceX" kostet ein
Raketenstart im Moment etwa 60 Millionen US-Dollar
und das meiste davon geht drauf,
um eine neue Rakete zu bauen!
Wenn man eine Rakete aber wiederverwenden könnte,
dann würden die Kosten auf den Treibstoff
und ein paar Reparaturen sinken!
Jetzt muss der "SpaceX" natürlich erstmal
beweisen, dass sie eine Rakete die
bereits im All war, wiederverwenden
können.
Die unglaublichen Temperaturschwankungen
und Belastungen bei einem Start,
nehmen Raketen natürlich ordentlich mit!
Die "Falcon 9" Rakete von gestern wird
übrigens nie wieder fliegen.
Zu hoch sei der emotionale Wert der ersten, sicheren Landung des Unternehmens.
Ob das nun wirklich stimmt oder ob mit der Rakete vielleicht etwas nicht in Ordnung ist,
werden wir wahrscheinlich nie erfahren...
Wenn die Landetechnik in vier Jahren ausgereift ist und man für einen Raketenstart
irgendwann noch ein Zehntel
der 60 Millionen Dollar Zahlen müsste,
dann könnten wir mehr Satelliten,
mehr Sonden
und mehr Menschen ins All bringen und
"SpaceX" könnte ihr ultimatives Ziel erreichen:
Den Mars zu bevölkern.
Und so komisch das auch klingt, den Mars zu bevölkern könnte und als Menschheit
das Überleben sichern!
Wie das funktioniert habe ich in diesem
Video erklärt: "Müssen wir alle sterben?"
Schaut es euch an um mehr über das Thema zu erfahren.
Und wenn euch das Video gefallen hat,
würde ich mich sehr über einen "Daumen nach oben" freuen.
Und wenn ihr Freunde oder Bekannte kennt,
denen das Video hier gefallen könnte,
dann teilt das gerne über "Facebook" oder "WhatsApp"!
Ich verabschiede mich hier in Weihnachtsferien!
Ich wünsche euch viel Spaß an Weihnachten
mit euren Familien!
Esst nicht zu viel bei Oma und
ansonsten wünsche ich euch:
"Frohe Weihnachten!"
Euer Cedric!